white sails as far as the eye can see
for one week every year the Keen fjord
is packed with sailing ships and boats
this year for the first time the regatta
will feature a new type of catamaran the
necra 17 with a mixed crew
Lisa a tamiya a member of germany's
national sailing team came up with an
unusual way to find a partner for the
competition tunisia pokémon pokémon hi
I'm Lisa and I need a man someone who
will be with me for a long time not just
for the keel week's events but until
2016 that's when the olympic games start
in rio
and thanks to that video she did find a
partner Italian Olympic sailor Pietro
sabelo he and his brother Jan Franco
have been sailing competitively for 15
years la belleza guns optimized it all
went so smoothly I thought they'd be a
huge difference working with Lisa Lisa a
bear finis turned out better than I
expected he ducked up he shouldn't have
been so surprised Sabella's family is
certainly no stranger to women from keel
his father took part in the sailing
events that were held here as part of
the 19 72 olympics my father is my
father came here from Italy to compete
and he met his future wife here the van
a young Maria she was 18 years old at
the time and worked at the Olympic
Center my father didn't win any medals
but he did find a wife so it'll worked
out firing from that's well burning wood
there it gave me this but Lisa a Tamiya
and Pietro sabelo are focused
exclusively on sailing the keel regatta
will be the first time they've worked
together they train for about a month
and got along fine
gonna be your sunglasses today yeah yeah
I hope we'll see some blue skies over
the people who've come to keel to enjoy
the regatta wouldn't mind seeing some
sunshine either lots of tourists come
down to the harbor to see the classic
sailing ships and those tourists come
from all over this is my best time in
the key Navajo experience ESO is really
amazing for me to be here missus in net
hot I like the atmosphere best of all
and when you walk around the city you
see a lot of different events
international cuisine people sailing
event event yeah and oh mother with you
can see the athletes up close and
personal but you can even watch them
getting set up for the competition
dinging can woody have a boat around
doesn't the weather isn't the best
neither for the sailing cruise nor for
the event organizers it's pretty tricky
today they set the starting line and
check to make sure that no crew starts
early
the German Italian team had a bit of a
slow start but fought its way to the
front of the first round Lisa had a hard
time with the turning maneuvers she
repeatedly had to bring in the blue
headsail and hoist it up again it's
physically demanding work four days in a
row with three races every day
and there were a few accidents along the
way like the time they collided with an
Argentine vote but overall Lisa and
Pietro managed to place fourth
Bob mission coyote it was a little
chaotic out there there was this cloud
and then an interesting gust of wind
whew man it was more than we expected
and then BAM it was all over goodbye
yeah that's good music I really enjoyed
it the weather keeps changing well okay
not when it's cold and rainy but the
wind was quite good be diseased egg wood
has led son the last race was just awful
I mean out there on the gennaker chorus
I couldn't hold on to the sale so i told
pietro about it and he said okay well
just ship the sale to the other side
Lisa and Pietro have to learn to work
together a little more closely but they
did make eighth place in the overall
standings and that's not a bad start it
was like I really enjoyed it I can learn
a whole lot from Pietro that's important
too I think I've really found the right
partner God now as you guys could my
local an estimated 4,500 people from
more than 50 countries take part in the
queue week sailing competition it's one
of the biggest events of its kind but
it's just the start for the San Pietro
you come to some diagonal these are two
people who have sailed completely
different boats in the past but in just
one month together they've really
managed to improve their skills I think
they did a fantastic job
their main goal now is to prepare for
the 2016 olympics and of course lisa
pietro have their sights set on winning
a medal